you got some good fortune recently you
play piano in a chipotle campaign yeah
are you a good pianist I cannot play the
piano we have a rupture of you in the ad
and this I would think and you can't you
can't play how did you get this part if
you don't play I didn't really don't
know like you don't see that's the only
time you see my hands right there and
I'm just like the directors like so just
kind of that's how badly I faked it I
was like is this right my friends are
like you didn't have any lines in that
commercial is that don't you want lines
and stuff but I think people's idea of
success is different I if I don't have
to say anything and something it's like
yes like that's the best yeah there's
nothing to memorize I can't screw it up
so how do you get a part where you how
does that work the audition how did it
work when they say do you you place you
show up prepared you just always have
the equipment that you're gonna need and
you know it was back there I did I
didn't know that was there I just looked
I was like oh this will help right now
yeah what if that was my audition all
right so we want you to be the Chipotle
guy I'm like
he's perfect he's perfect they
definitely didn't hire me because of my
good looks I know we're on that as a
person so when I couldn't play the piano
and I had no lines and I look like this
it's like did my wife sleep with
somebody to get me yeah how did you get
it yeah she may have slept with somebody
are you good at IJ need to play the PIO
an impression of a guy who lied on his
resume about being able to play the
piano and got hired to work in a hotel
lobby and now he's just trying to get
through it oh so this is a guy who said
he could he's there and he has to play
now this is a guy who said he lied
tonight forget the setup yeah this is a
guy piano Hotel lying think about being
in a hotel lobby right you're just there
to check in you don't know what's going
on also who are you to turn around and
go that guy's not really playing you
would never do that guys real what are
incidentals again tell me this isn't a
writ I want someone to tell me that they
are certain this is not a real song
[Music]
that's right
nobody cuz it might be a real Sun that
could be a song well a it could that guy
when he has confidence he just goes it
like if he works there three weeks and
nobody said a word
he's like happy our people are drinking
so don't even
[Laughter]
it's all about confidence
you